I wanted my husband to come home from the office
to eat lunch with me today,
so I told him I was making a Mcchicken.
It worked. I mixed up my sourdough buns the night before
using my primitive wheat and corn,
the healthiest wheat on earth
because it hasn't been altered in the lab to have more gluten
and isn't sprayed with glyphosate.
This took about 10 minutes of prep time
and in the morning it was perfectly fermented.
I shaped the dough into eight sourdough buns using a dough scraper
and rolled each bun into a round ball,
then let those rise about two hours on a our baking sheet.
Around 11:00am,
I place the buns in the oven to bake for about 12 minutes
while I prepared the nugget center
by removing breasts and legs from my whole pasture raised chicken.
I turn these pieces into chopped chicken
by using the escalator in a food processor.
Next I mixed up my flour dunk,
a combination of iron corn flour,
salt, pepper and spices,
making round patties about three and a/2 ounces in size.
I dunk each in the flour, then into the same mixture,
which I later added baking soda and water to.
This went straight into hot schmaltz
and cooked for several minutes per side
until crispy and golden. While the nuggets sizzled in the pan,
I finely chopped some iceberg lettuce
and whipped up some homemade Mayo.
When the nugget came out of the pan,
I placed A bun into the hot smelts and let that get nice and golden.
Then I prepared the Mcchicken by first spreading the Mayo,
then layering with a handful of iceberg,
and lastly the nugget. My husband walked in the door
just as I finished compiling his Mcchicken.
We both enjoyed the best sandwich we've ever bitten into,
although I was nervous to see what he really thought.
He turned out loving it, just as I hoped he would,
so I'm sure I'll be able to get him back home for lunch in the future.